Moi, avec mon chat,
on a vraiment un bon feeling.
À aucun moment, je regrette
de l'avoir adopté. Faux !
J'ai acheté
une laisse pour les chats.
Mais je comprends pas
pourquoi ça existe, ce genre de truc,
vu qu'il refuse absolument
de se faire promener.
On dirait qu'en fait,
je promène son cadavre.
C'est bon, j'ai trouvé une solution.
Moi, mon chat, il y a un truc
qu'il apprécie vraiment faire,
c'est miauler
près de 4 millions de fois par jour
pour aucune raison.
Par contre, au moment où je dois partir,
que je suis bien en speed
et que je l'appelle
pour vérifier s'il est là,
il a vraiment l'intelligence
de ne plus miauler du tout.
Ce gros con !
Sergi ! Sergi ! Sergi !
Je rigole plus, là.
Toute façon, moi, je n'arrive pas
à bien l'éduquer, mon chat.
À chaque fois qu'il fait une connerie,
à la fois je le dispute, mais en même temps
je le trouve trop mignon, alors je lui fais
plein de bisous et il doit rien capter.
Pourquoi t'as volé
mon petit bout de jambon ? Hein ?
Mais qu'est-ce qu'il me raconte ?
Je ne comprends pas. C'est bien ou c'est pas bien ?
Mais les chats, ils ont une façon de penser
qu'on ne peut pas comprendre.
Par exemple, je vais acheter un jouet pour chat
d'une valeur inestimable, parfaitement sophistiqué.
Il y joue près de zéro seconde.
Par contre, il a trouvé ce bout de plastique,
issu d'un paquet de gâteaux,
et ça, pour lui, c'est vraiment
la plus grosse éclate du monde.
Tu vois, c'est vraiment
très, très drôle.
C'est marrant parce que, quand t'as un chat
et que tu reçois des invités,
très vite, tu te rends compte de qui
est habitué à avoir un chat et qui ne l'est pas.
Houlà, houlà, il y a le chat qui vient
sur moi, là, direct. Tu dis rien ?
Il fait ses griffes, là.
Il en train de me griffer.
Ah, il perd ses poils, en plus.
J'étais allergique avant, quand j'étais petit.
Il en train de me donner des coups, là.
Moi, dans ma famille, on avait un hamster.
D'ailleurs, je me demandais,
si un jour je rentre chez moi,
et que mon chat est décédé,
qu'est-ce que je fais du corps ? Où je le mets ?
Ce qui est quand même
très pratique, avec un chat,
c'est que le matin, il peut te réveiller.
Ça fait fonction réveil.
Par contre, c'est une heure
complètement aléatoire.
Pourquoi tu m'as réveillé ?
Il est huit heures !
Je suis désolé,
je n'ai pas de cerveau !
En tout cas, malgré
ces petits problèmes sans importance,
avoir un chat,
c'est un vrai bonheur.
Moi, mon chat, je lui donne plein d'amour
et il sait me le rendre.
Tu veux aller te promener ?
>> [Miaou]
Stop !
Ce message n'a aucun rapport.
Depuis quelque temps, il y a l'application
"Norman fait des vidéos"
qui est sortie pour les téléphones
de type cellulaire.
Il y a déjà plein de gens qui l'ont téléchargée
et qui lui ont mis une bonne note.
Alors merci,
c'est cool.
Certains se demandent
peut-être à quoi ça sert.
En fait, c'est pour recevoir toutes mes vidéos
directement à la seconde où elles sortent.
Tu peux consulter
toutes mes anciennes vidéos.
Je peux aussi envoyer plein de petits messages en push,
que j'ai écrit moi-même avec mes petits doigts.
Il y a une soundbox
où il y a plein de sons rigolos,
Amazing !
Tu peux faire des blagues
à tes copains.
Il y a aussi plein de petites plaisanteries
cachées dans l'application,
parce que moi,
j'aime bien rigoler.
Et elle est totalement
gratuite pour tous.
Voilà, vous pouvez la télécharger.
À bientôt !